hey everybody and welcome to a very
unflattering wild ride clip you know we
all do stuff that we don't want
everybody to see and for the stuff you
really don't want anybody to see best to
be protected by nordvpn Yep they're
bringing you this clip so enjoy it and
stick around to the very end yeah dude
and I I have to like with effort try to
have the the Rogan mentality and then
over the years I've really been more
like uh but are you like that with
people doing stunts trying to help
people out for sure look at the waves
you know but you don't know but you've
never been like ah dude this guy can't
do it or like it's kind of weird that
this guy or have you always been because
like when people are showing you like
when jackass came out everybody was me
and my friends right everybody started
making jackass like yeah
that's our thing I I admitted you had to
have seen it in uh in my book where the
last thing I did with Ryan Dunn was this
show Minute to Win It okay right where
we both went on it and I'm like yeah
this is like it's kind of a while back
like it was in 2011 and uh and I
admitted in my book that when when we
got called for that I was campaigning to
like have it be just me because I went I
felt like that I'd like I'm a bigger
star like it'll be cooler like yeah if
I'm just you know I was trying to get
done kicked off oh that's crazy that's
crazy and and right when I say that I'm
like dude I understand that that that's
a [ __ ] shitheaded thing yeah this is
true like I'm a [ __ ] you know like
that's how that's where I was at yeah
so yeah you were like that yeah 100 I'm
a Marin
yeah I'm a Marin dude and I'm working
hard to be more of a Rogan yeah it's
hard to be real good yeah it's dead it's
it's tough man yeah I think that's why
it's so successful I can feel my face is
like red I'm embarrassed from that no
that happens it's not red
but yeah you know your face gets hot
like it's the worst yeah if you go to
nordvpn.com
Stevo you will get a huge discount on
your plan plus for free months and it's
totally risk-free with a risk-free
30-day money-back guarantee
yeah dude